and this is a topic that we kind of
stumbled over last night as it relates
to the compensation that is devoted to
quarterbacks because there's there's
been a trend in recent years where you
see a great young quarterback and
there's an urgency to put a team around
him and spend money around him before
you've got to pay him and there's this
presumption that once you get a
quarterback that at least is what in the
top half you do everything you can to
keep him but I'm not so sure that some
of these guys Chris that have gotten big
contracts really should have gotten big
contracts so our challenge whether we
accept it or not for this segment will
be to identify which quarterbacks truly
are the guys you've got to pay whatever
it takes to keep and which guys
conversely maybe they shouldn't have
been paid and maybe their guys out there
that should not get that big money and
they should should either not be
re-signed or or signed to a far lower
amount than what they're looking for so
I you know with that said I'm gonna let
you pick the first one and I think we
agree on the guy right now that needs to
be paid whatever it takes to keep him
around for the rest of his career yeah I
mean even Patrick mahomes is that who
we're talking about right at the top of
the list yeah your homie my homie
Patrick Mahoney yes he is
without question I mean I think you know
it's been one year so you know we might
be you know jumping the gun a little bit
or whatever and they were not we're not
you're right because we saw special
things we know he's a special talent and
yes he does
classify under I would pay anything to
have that guy as the quarterback of my
franchise for the future he's that
special of a player you know he's this
is Dan Marino 1984 this is Elway this is
Aaron Rodgers this is Brett Favre this
is a guy that can change the whole
dynamic of your franchise for the next
10 to 15 years yeah I mean III know when
they're big great players who have
arrived on the scene in the past the
defense's that will be facing them the
following year spend the full seven
months figuring out what they're gonna
do and I know defense isn't gonna do
that to Patrick
they're gonna study what the Patriots
did I think Tyreke hill is gonna see a
lot of double coverage like you saw in
the AFC championship game but I don't
think it's gonna matter no whatever your
plan is Patrick mahomes is still gonna
make his place because when things start
to break down and chaos ensues that's
when he rises above everyone that's his
that's his best tool right you can try
to out scheme the other team and
sometimes that's gonna work when it
doesn't work yeah that's when mahomes
dips into his bag of tricks and he uses
his athletic ability to run circles
around everyone and eventually fire a
missile to an open receiver you're
exactly right like New England game it's
it's oh it's 30 seconds and they need a
field goal to kick to tie the game and
send it to over overtime against New
England nobody can do that oh the
perfect coverage perfect defense he
escapes the pocket and throws a rifle
down the sideline to the running back
where for a big gain and all of a sudden
you go wow they're gonna get in field
goal range here that's what you're
talking about and that is what kind of
special player he is and keep in mind
with the rules currently are it used to
be that you could sign a draft pick to a
new contract after two years in the NFL
the 2011 cba requires teams to wait
three years mahomes is entering his
third season but if you look at the
language carefully once the regular
season ends that's when the window opens
for a long-term deal if I'm the Chiefs
I've got a package ready yeah Patrick
mahomes then I put in front of him the
day after week 17 of the 2019 season at
that moment let's do this right now
because every day you wait after that
it's only gonna get more expensive yeah
you're right and at the same time if
Patrick mahomes doesn't want to sign
something like that he's got to give
himself some security that three to four
years from now when he's still the best
quarterback in football that he's not
being jumped by no-name guys that we're
gonna make up or talk about right now
who don't deserve to be in his
stratosphere right whether that's a Kirk
Cousins or whoever it may be they've got
to have a provision like that to to help
some of these guys out in these
situations but he's certainly that guy I
mean do you want to go Aaron Rodgers
we're putting dressed the point you just
made yeah because Aaron Rodgers when he
was negotiating the most recent contract
by the way his last contract he
committed for like six years which was a
mistake
and he talked about creativity and
different things they can do at the end
of the day he just accepted what the
packers offered a standard structure
with no protection against getting
leapfrogged no provision that ties into
a percentage of the salary cap which is
available but no team will do it mahomes
could be the guy to get it yeah that
could be the guy to change things but
the next guy on your list as we are
discussing Aaron Rodgers a guy that you
should pay anything to yes without
question I mean he's still in the prime
of his career maybe just on the start of
the downhill side of that you know slope
he's no longer peak performance Aaron
Rodgers we've seen injuries a little bit
credit you know creep into his career at
this point but at 34 years old this day
and age at the quarterback position with
lack of contact and lack of being able
to hit the quarterback you know the
knowledge of players staying healthy for
a long time and taking care of their
body the Tom Brady effect you know but
Aaron Rodgers has got four or five six
years of really good football I think
still ahead of them because he's got a
special arm he's a special athlete and
hey you know my thoughts on Aaron
Rodgers he's the greatest quarterback I
have ever seen in my life
I I don't care about rings and all of
that I'm talking about when it comes to
the attributes he can bring to the
football field
there is nobody that's been able to
compare quick release strong arm quick
feet in the pocket a gunslinger that
never throws interceptions the greatest
touchdown to interception ratio in the
history of the sport that's why he is
you know in this class that we're
talking about
we saw Peyton Manning we saw Brett Favre
we Joe Montana we saw Johnny Unitas we
saw Joe Namath we've seen plenty of
great quarterbacks over the years
finished their careers with other teams
you think Rogers is wire-to-wire a Green
Bay Packer I do I think he'll be
wire-to-wire a Green Bay Packer I do I I
think I think he's the type of guy and
when he doesn't feel like he's got it
anymore or he can't just dominate he'll
just call it quits and say sia and move
on to the next phase of life when you
say that he's starting down the back end
of his prime right do you think if he
hears that do you think deep down he
agrees or do you think he puts you on
the same list that I'm on well yeah he
probably puts me on the list but he's I
think he's a realistic enough guy and a
smart enough guy to go well you know I
mean I get what he's saying I am 34
years old and got a
35 and all that I hope he's smart enough
but this is what makes guys like Brady
and Rogers who they are this
unbelievable self belief and you know
self confidence and almost this
narcissist narcissist type of way and I
mean that in a good way that makes them
be able to go out in front of 70,000 s
and say hey screw you we're down by 10
I'm gonna bring us back that's what
makes them great - so you got to take a
little bit of both there it's always
important to have self-confidence
exactly exactly when you're ready right
okay so where do we go from here we got
my home's yeah Rogers who's the next
quarterback out there that you pay
whatever it takes to keep I only got
three more guys on my list total just
for me I don't know and you could push
back but Russell Wilson would be that
guy okay
deshaun Watson would be that guy for me
and your luck would be that guy right
now everybody else I don't think as that
guy and I know there might be some
pushback or whatever and I feel free to
push back you're very concerned about
the push pal I'm just saying I got shown
the ropes and I even thrown a punt oh
I'm just saying you know guys like Matt
Ryan he's awesome but I think he's the
next tier down I get that okay you know
Cam Newton I think he's that type of
talent but the part of his career and
his banged up as he's been I don't think
he fits into that you know Brees and
Brady
they're amazing still don't get me wrong
but they're old so I'm not paying
anything for them at this point of their
career I guess that's how I kind of
differentiates you know some of those
guys as being the next level down
compared to the big five mahomes Rogers
Watson Wilson and luck
what about Roethlisberger yeah
Roethlisberger I think is the same thing
like still awesome and doing great
things on the football field but a
little too old for me to say oh I'm
gonna give him Aaron Rodgers type money
or you know Russell Wilson when he's up
here soon
that type of contract I think he's that
next phase down type of guy where hey I
could I could sit here and go he
certainly deserves more than Derek Carr
and deserves something in the the Kirk
Cousins type of range but I don't think
I could justify him being in the Aaron
Rodgers our soon-to-be mahomes Wilson
range all right there were five
first-round quarterbacks last year
they've
all worked out so far the best to the
bunch by far in my estimation Baker made
yeah he's he on the list he did another
year from it no I I would like to see
another year but I did think about him
like a little bit like we saw with
Patrick mahomes I mean I almost saw
enough to go okay he's the guy he's the
man let's go go let's do this going
forward I think he's very close to that
category for everything that he brings
to the table not alone not just his
great physical talent but the guy the
leader the charisma he shows in the
locker room I think if I saw another
good half of half of a year this year in
the 2019 season I would put him in that
class of guys and you know I've seen the
stats and I'm sure we've talked about
this before how all of the highest-paid
quarterbacks in the NFL didn't make it
to the playoffs this year and teams have
to ask themselves and it may just be
that teams are paying the wrong guys
because what's your alternative you've
got Derek Carr right and Derek Carr has
been good enough and now he's due for a
contract what do you do they made him
the highest-paid player in the history
of football then Matthew Stafford he
gets his contract he's the highest-paid
player and then Jimmy Garoppolo gets his
and Kirk Cousins gets his and and I
guess these teams are you're so
desperate to have that guy who is gonna
transcend the franchise that you you you
pay I didn't hope it works out yeah I
think there should be a little bit of a
difference between you know those top
two your guys in some of these middle
class quarterbacks you know it's again
where the quarterback in the last 10 to
15 years has become the most powerful
person and organizations he's one up the
head coaches it's really owner and then
right behind that is franchise
quarterback that's all we talk about but
I would like to remind people you know
hey let's build a team okay let's build
a team the Eagles built a team and then
when their star quarterback went down
Nick Foles won the Peyton Manning
Broncos that we discussed earlier when
he was the worst rated quarterback in
football they had a team they had a
great defense they did a pretty decent
running game they managed the game right
hey how about Russell Wilson in this
first Super Bowl Russell Wilson was
nothing special at that point he was
really good but they were about defense
and running the ball and Percy Harvin
returned
kicks how about Tom Brady early on in
his career I mean he threw for a hundred
and forty-five yards in his first Super
Bowl that he won and got MVP why because
the team around him was great so
sometimes the team helps the building of
that franchise quarterback and starts
that whole process where I think two too
many times especially in recent past
where teams just go oh this is the
franchise quarterback he's our guy and
he'll carry us through no you still have
to take their approach I build the team
and the quarterback then might get to a
point where he can carry you from that
point on
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports